Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody, I want to start
today with something that's really interesting,
but not super surprising, which is that the
United States coronavirus vaccination map
looks just like the 20 20 presidential election
results map.
If you want to predict which states voted
for Trump, look at the states that aren't
really getting vaccinated at the higher rates
in the country.
If you want to predict which states are getting
vaccinated, look at the list of states where
Joe Biden got more of a share of the vote
relative to Donald Trump.
And it's actually incredible how accurately
this can predict vaccination.
If you look at the top twenty five states
in terms of what portion of the population
has been vaccinated, Joe Biden won twenty
one of those twenty five states in the twenty
twenty election.
When you look at the bottom twenty five states
in terms of vaccination rate, Donald Trump
won twenty one of those twenty five states,
including 16 of the worst 17 states.
When it comes to vaccination, the correlation
between vaccination rate and the twenty twenty
election outcome by state has strengthened
over time.
And that's another important thing to consider.
We've talked about how anti vaccine sentiment
has declined over time.
Even among Republicans, like, for example,
last month, 43 percent of Republicans didn't
want the vaccine.
This month, only 41 percent of Republicans
don't want the vaccine.
Even within that, if you are a Republican
in a blue state, you are far more likely to
want a vaccine than if you are a Republican
in a red state.
Now, in addition to this, there's a big urban
rural divide when it comes to vaccination,
just like there is an urban rural divide in
Trump versus Biden.
But let's put some visuals to this for people
who are watching us today.
Check out some of these images from A.S.A.
sign ups, dot net.
This is a chart, a vaccination rate versus
Trump support at the state level.
And you see that the numbers are arranged
along a diagonal line to the right.
It is a higher Trump vote and you see a lower
vaccination rate.
It's just a perfect plot.
To the left is a higher Biden vote and you
see much higher vaccination rates.
Now, you could say, hold on a second, David.
Hold on, sir.
States vary in population.
You have really big blue states and you have
some really small red states.
So if you just look at states that could be
deceptive, it might not really give us an
accurate picture of this.
The second image here from ACA sign ups dot
net is county by county.
And similarly, although you have more outliers,
like there are some blue counties where very
few people want to get vaccinated, I would
love to know where those are, but it's basically
the same pattern pattern, higher trump vote,
lower vaccination, higher Biden vote, higher
vaccination.
And it only requires thinking back to the
last, what, 15, 16 months to understand what's
going on here.
If you have been told for a year by your fearless
leader, this isn't serious, this is like the
flu, 15 cases will soon be zero.
We don't need masks.
We don't need to close.
We need kids in schools.
You might get the sense that you don't really
need a vaccine and thus you aren't going to
go and get yourself one.
Trump said it would be gone in April, last
April of not one month ago.
Thirteen months ago.
Why would you need a vaccine for that?
But the real tragedy here is that politicizing
the tax rate, OK, you know, politicizing debt
and deficit, that's one thing.
If something that is simply a public health
measure that saves lives like a vaccination
that is 90 plus percent effective, if that
can fall into the same political traps, the
same political games, then quite literally
anything can.
And that's a horrifying reality to have to
accept.
There are trumpets now posting to social media
like a badge of honor that they have not and
they will not get vaccinated and the government's
not going to tread on them and force them
to get vaccinated.
Well, yeah, no, the government's not going
to force you to do it.
Of course we know that.
But they are wearing this lack of vaccination
as a badge of honor now.
So at the end of the day, Trump's politicization
of the pandemic continues.
Trump's gone, but it will continue to cause
deaths, American deaths due to this anti vaccine
sentiment.
And increasingly because of this partizan
split, Trump's mishandling and propagandizing
around the pandemic will lead to more Republican
deaths than Democratic deaths, as we have
increasingly.
I mean, there are blue states that are at
70 percent vaccinated already.
That's essentially herd immunity.
Cases are going to zero almost statistically,
not literally zero statistically zero, where
you get down to a number that are the rate
of reproduction is extremely low.
This is an incredible situation because it
is going to take on an incredible partizan
divide as we go forward with red state and
Republican clusters of the virus.
It's a horrible thing.
And I don't care what your partizan identification
is, I don't want anybody to die.
I don't want anybody to get sick.
And we are very quickly seeing an incredible
red, blue divide happening when it comes to
vaccination